hi it's time to do some foliage work on
the invert because basically if I finish
this foliage stuff right now
I'm pretty much finished everything I
need to do on this invert so I'm all
done with that and I can move on to
other things such as the intimate LSM
that I'm working on right now now the
foliage is just going to be very simple
or at least it's gonna be very similar
to the foliage that I've done in the
lower part of the ride it is gonna be
basically I might want to explain more
how I do this so I'm using I mean upset
what kinds of sets I've been using but
maybe it would be nice actually say how
I'm using everything and why so
basically I'm using station gyms I need
to stop saying that word I am using
station gyms gone in in 2.54 many things
because it's an amazing set but
basically there's that oh my god why do
I keep doing that
there is that one fern plant that I've
been talking about earlier and I just
want to use that everywhere so I have
some grown shrubbery I'm not actually
I'm not using too much other stuff for
that ground foliage there's a bit of the
flowers from n7s and sevens floors and
and sevens I don't know what it's called
ornamental shrubs that's the name but
most of it is actually that fern looking
thing from stating Jim's gardening 2.5
and that's pretty much all of the ground
foliage you don't need that much brown
foliage actually if you're using pines
and stuff like that because they are
they already have the leaves on the
ground level so you don't really need it
over there there's not space for it
anyway so yeah speaking of the pines and
stuff like that I'm using 2.5 for those
sexy dark pines and there are two kinds
if you can kind of see it you have the
one with the more wider well look I
didn't really know how to explain it but
basically I - two types of pines that
I'm using from station gems 2.5 station
gyms gardening 2.5 and then there's that
one tree which I also forgot the name of
I just keep forgetting names of trees
really I used them but other than that I
wouldn't know too much about them but
there's that one tree that I use quite
regularly because it just has an amazing
texture so that's that and that's most
of it really
then there's spices trees and spices
trees is always kind of my backdrop I've
been talking about backdrops and three
lines are stuff like that and basically
you I said it again so what you kind of
wants or at least what I usually do is
to display some trees in the background
that kind of block the view of the
grasslands that you don't really want to
see and most of the times I used to
spices trees for that because it's a set
that has very good-looking trees but
they're very low in Pawleys so you don't
really get lag from them and they have a
very nice dark looking texture that goes
with pretty much all of the all of the
custom scenery sets that are out there
for foliage so really it's a good one to
build tree lines with but I also like to
do some of the lines from the station
gems but no spices trees for it just
well regular pine works and then there
is a set that I've been talking about
earlier on it's n sevens also known as I
think it's also known as Mike's
ornamental shrubs but most commonly its
and seven fundamental shrubs which has
those amazing little I don't know what
they're called but they're purple and
yellow bushes with amazing flowers so I
always like to use those things because
they're awesome and I haven't really
talked about this console yet but I just
felt like on a whim I just decided to
build that costume over there so that's
why I did that I'm still not too certain
about it I mean I kind of wanted this
right to be only forest but then when I
did it I felt like it was too boring I
just felt like there wasn't you know
variation in the kind of kinds of
scenery that you had around the ride but
now I actually don't feel too sure about
the castle and you don't really see it
from the ride so the force is kind of
too dense to see it however you do see
that tower awkwardly well in the middle
of the mountain range so I don't know if
it's something that I really want but
I'll just let it stay but basically the
inverse is finished now I just kind of
wanted to do the area around it so this
little plaza over here needs benches
because I took some pictures of it and
did some filming material just kind of
seeing what it looks like and it just
annoyed me that there were no benches or
anything really for that matter on the
paths so I just decided to place that
while I was at it I decided to try some
new lamps that I rarely ever use from
very obscure custom see
reset and then it was time to tackle the
terraforming and do the good old
checkerboard pattern
well terrain textures again because
everybody loves those things I mean it
takes a bit of time but it actually
doesn't take that much I I was looking
at the I was looking at this video when
I recorded it and realized that doing
this doesn't even take that much time as
you're so boring that it seems to take a
lot of time but it's not even that great
of a portion of the time-lapse oh really
it's not that bad to do it it's not that
time-consuming it's just kind of
annoying
but I found out that it was somewhat fun
or at least not that boring to add sand
everywhere and just kind of scatter that
around and see what that would look like
and the second part of doing this and
filling in that the grass spaces is
actually something that is kind of fun
because you can see what the cross is
going to look like I mean the first the
first section of doing that checkerboard
technique is always boring just making
the checkerboard and it looks ugly and
everything but what I'm doing now is
just filling everything in I don't know
why but I always like to do that just
seeing that the terrain transform it's
like it's like you put a layer on it
like something like like I don't know
how to how to describe it but it's kind
of like when you place a fence around
the building and say that you're working
on it and then you finish the building
but basically you don't see the building
yet and then you remove this and then
you remove the fence so you're like oh
so that's how it looks now that's
basically that kind of feeling I got
from doing this and as soon as I get
that little area done in the corner over
there I've pretty much done all of the
terrain texturing in the park so hooray
I don't have to do this anymore or at
least I hope so I don't I'm not entirely
sure of course plus I I will probably
add another section to the park I still
need to add a kind of kids area and an
area with more flat rides because I'm
going to add a flat right next to the
castle and might as well put another one
over there next to the intimate LSM but
then again I've got three rollercoasters
I think but they're pretty big and if
you have about three rollercoasters I
would go for about ten flat rides or
something like that
but what I need to do before I actually
get to doing that is installing new CF
ice because I don't have any sea of ice
on this computer yet just a couple of CT
CF ice that I need for this park but
nothing else and yeah that's basically
that so then I decided to just kind of
see where I would go with this path
because I kind of wanted to try
something else something that I hadn't
done in this park yet so I just decided
to go with Brian just set and see what
it looks like and it looks pretty decent
though I'm not too sure about the height
of the fence and it doesn't really fit
the rest of the Pike that's well I think
it fits it well enough and of course I
kind of want to mix different fence sets
together you don't want to use the same
fences everywhere I mean it's not an
idea that I got myself it's actually an
7 who posted that in a threat somewhere
when I figured hey that's actually a
very good idea so yeah I would like to
spread the message and if you can try
using various fence sets because it just
looks cooler if you have various pen
sets and this is where I decided to do
the supporting on the instrument and so
that's done as well now the only problem
with this is I was very done and
actually call it them in the wrong color
I used this very light kind of purple
and now I can see it right away I have
no clue how I didn't see it at the time
I was listening to Pink Floyd or
something and spacing out too much I
don't know why but that just happened
but yeah that's what I needed I needed
to recolor them at some point so I was I
was being an amazing again and then I
pretty much did everything when it comes
to this ride and the support and all
that and it's just a senior you know I
still need to do and I still actually
don't have a clue how this entire area
is going to look because I've been
working on scenery I know in this area
quite quite for quite a bit now but I
still actually don't have an idea of
what the area is going to look like most
of the times I do have an idea and I
would recommend everyone to actually
build buildings with at least having a
slight idea in my head because even
though I often say that I don't blame my
rides which is true I never make
sketches or plans for anything I do
often come up with something in my head
even if it's just right before I build
it I kind of do construct a plan in my
head but I just decided to not do that
with this roller coaster and just the
complete random things and I suppose I'm
taking quite a risk there because it
might turn into something terrible so I
really hope it's not going to happen
like that but I guess I'll see at some
point I might want to kind of formulate
a plan right now and actually see where
I can go with the buildings that I've
built so far so yeah that's basically me
trying to recolor all those things which
actually turn out to be a rather
annoying job because the footage and
supports and stuff had different kinds
of color schemes and then I figured it
was time to work on that Tower and
speaking of plans now that I'm on the
topic of that I actually don't have a
plan for this hour either it's that it's
that kind of building why I felt like
okay I'm gonna build a building like
this but I really had no clue how I was
going to do it so I really hope that
this building is not going to look too
terrible because if there's anything
that kind of annoys me they're all like
oh so they can through even though I
know I have nobody to blame except for
myself when it comes to that is when I
build a building and I've worked so hard
on it and then I finished it and I'm
looking at it and I'm like I messed up
that's probably one of the worst
feelings I'd rather have rollercoaster
kanthri crash than having that because I
know it's my fault that I've pretty much
wasted hours of my life and then I need
to remove the fruits of my labor and
that just hurts but yeah that's pretty
much it for this episode see you in the
next one and